hey guys welcome to the rumen report i'm
dave rubin
we are doing a one on one this week we
have a guy who needs no introduction
and truly a living legend about that
intro
dead legit better than a dead leg in
larry king welcome to the room in
reporting your name
great to be with you always have love
having you on my show and scraped to
return the compliment I appreciate that
actually the first time I was on your
show I am sweating
bit when we did that Republican National
Convention and you told
that you told me I was sweating more
than albert brooks in broadcast news
which is
truly one of the greatest moment in my
career broadcast news is one bit
all-time great
movies I think great great movie about
the media
well for everything we do right and for
me especially because
I saw that movie two weeks after
quintuple bypass surgery well
and i sat next to Mike Wallace arisen
Diane so the whole
the whole in crowded New York in my
surgery was in New York
so we all attended that film in
everybody loved
yeah I will you know let's start with a
little bit about the media so you have
been around the media for basically your
whole life in at least 57 years
57 years but who's counting what what do
you think you're the biggest changes
in the way the media landscape as you
know you're you're doing an online show
now
we're doing some major changes one
technical
in that when I started there was a radio
and television
landlines and telephone lines and then
came satellites and now we have
internet not long ago technological and
has been incredible
and that has led to five hundred
channels in anything goes in
you know when jackie gleason went off
the air
he have $13.3 million viewers there was
no show the
that approach is $20 million viewers so
the
the pie is cut up in many many slices
and we all have a little piece a slice
piece a pyro so when I left
CNN I thought I could retire then along
came Carlos lemon
the internet now I'm on the internet
every day who knows
who knows what's next the delivery
system now
the basic hasn't changed this one-on-one
has not changed we still need the human
being
it has bad hasn't changed the method of
delivery
has changed are we losing something with
the one-on-one I mean really what your
trademark is this what we're doing right
now
we don't get that in a way that we use
noon sadly enough because it's a
is spirit heated up speed about Gordon
actually
no course there's up grab some jump on
it stay
bang it out but men go was over it was
next and love it leads to
I'm some %uh vid is up sir d- I miss
in-depth interviews you don't see much
in that
anymore on on cable television on you
know it's going away everywhere
said do you think it's just a function
of technology or is there actually
something else go is there something
about
humans and the way we're evolving under
no babies but Youmans or or about
management or about the people running
networks now or will call
suits mmm they didn't go up to broadcast
their captains
they're up to that pushes you know
they're big big world what this works
that does or keep business there's a war
going on
classic example was it mile network CNN
which is
I'm I loved every day on my twenty five
and a half years there
I did a lot for them they did a lot for
me it was a great career ted turner was
the best person I've worked for
work I didn't speak to to this bigoted
recently but if he saw was going on now
for example the airplane yet with let's
go another example
then covered that 24 hours a day they
missed
in you had the russians going into
Ukraine
the other day in one day i watch the
show on C after the show but
they never mention other news was
airplay yeah
and and the airplane was all conjecture
we think it landed here we might have
gone he would be
since day to day man that advanced
nothing in that story
but conjecture it was breaking the
supposition
breaking the speculation was never
breaking news
so if you were there now I don't know
what the hell with that but he
all item II love insisted the two other
things %uh they were said we got a
tremendous audience
then well the network I would've gone or
I with there's nothing I could do was to
break it
I would have tried heard for example the
other day
while CNN and some other cable news
networks I'm sure we're doing
airplane coast to coast wire to wire
10 people in Washington
yup were killed in a mudslide they would
three Americans on a plane
10 Americans died in a mudslide in
washington no coverage
the g8 conference in Russia was
cancelled
reschedule for Belgium with Russia left
out
no mention an enormous
enormous occurrence in Houston up an oil
slick
that described hundreds and hundreds of
miles
water not covered the president of the
united states
is in the Netherlands he's talking to
china
about trying to get China to at least a
neutral in the russian situation
no coverage yet know that is abysmal
so who do we blame for this because I
I'm with you everybody Matt Mills this
but it is a matter above readings
bridges ladies purses logic
yeah so why did so we hear about it but
the and the reason that that doesn't
work is
or you get super ratings and you think
advertisers don't know
that these ratings are based on the
hyped up there okay
to what happens after the incident is
over whenever dance and you gotta decide
when this and when is a public lose
interest
when you go back to your the program
missing down again the advertising gonna
buy it for the next six months
based on that too with jump because they
don't know what it was like
buying I'm gonna buy CBS I wanna buy
NBC per year because boy the Super Bowl
did great
I rests on sobel the great I've been to
buy NBC next tuesday
a normal person has nothing to do with
the other but thats
let's think and it's it's said to be